- David?
David, David?
- Oh god, Finn
Wolfhard made me do it!
- It's me, it's Josh, it's Josh!
- Josh!
Josh!
(laughing)
What's up, man, what's up?
- What's up with you,
what are you doing?
- Just a little guerilla
marketing for my one man show.
David Harbour, an artistic
exploration of sound,
light, and the soullessness
of celebrity culture.
- Oh.
- Hey, you should come
see a dress rehearsal!
I need honest feedback.
- Yeah, of course.
- Great.
- Just tell me where
and when, I'm there.
- Do you know that alley?
The one next to the other alley?
- So, are you a
friend of David's too?
(laughing)
(coughing)
(slow eerie music)
- I'm now going to tell you
about the first time
that I masturbated.
- Jesus.
(playful rhythmic music)
- Celeb-you-tain-ment,
celeb-you tainted.
(rattling)
Can you dig it?
Oh.
(light drumming)
Is this me?
Oh, wait, oh no!
Does it hurt you?
Is that painful to you?
Is it painful to you?
Celebrity deification is
a scourge of our society!
Read Chomsky, read Ñiñek.
So, how was the first act?
(laughs)
What do you think?
- Well, it's very
avant-garde
- Awesome
Awesome.
- Avant-garde
- Yeah.
- It's unusual.
- You like it, that's cool.
- Just being honest.
- Second act is
- It's weird.
- You know, more
Stranger Things stuff.
It's like I'm kind of pandering
to the fans, you know.
- Sometimes pandering
is a good thing to do.
- You're alive, Papa!
I hate you!
Well you're a brat.
B-R-A-T, brat.
(cries)
(sobs)
(moans)
That was the second act,
what do you think?
- You want my honest
feedback, right?
- Yeah, sure.
- I liked when you
played both roles.
- You got them.
- Yeah, I got that.
I do think you're getting,
some of the dialogue
a little wrong.
- Mind powers go.
- I also think some
of your recollections
about the Stranger
Things characters
is a little off.
- Name's Jack.
Jack Demogorgon.
I'm a monster
from the inside out.
You know, they don't let me
read the full scripts, Josh.
- And then, there's the dancing.
(dramatic music)
- That's about my
new film Hellboy,
and about the futility of fame.
- I didn't get that from that.
I gotta go man.
- Wait wait wait wait.
No because I have a puppet show
about rampant consumerism
and the time the Joe Keery
stole my Golden
Globe gift basket.
- I've been here
six hours, okay?
- Yeah, I know.
- No, I'm sorry man.
- Josh
- No, mm-mm.
- We're almost halfway through.
- He doesn't
understand you, David.
- You know what,
I'm starting to think
you might not be the
right manager for me.
(laughs)
(coughs)
(cries)